a very warm welcome
to all our viewers and in this video we
will be looking at excel automation in
uipath
stay tuned till the end of the video we
will be discussing
excel automation in detail and at last
there is a hands-on demo
if you want to know more about uipath
then you can check out our ui part
tutorial
let's look at today's agenda we will
start with understanding what is excel
automation
and why do we use an excel automation
what is the necessity of using it
also we shall look at some of the
advantages of excel automation
then we will jump in uipath studio and
see how to install an
excel package and see some of the
commonly used excel activities
finally we will look at hands-on demo
but before we begin
if you love watching tech videos then
subscribe to our youtube channel
and make sure you press the bell icon to
never miss an update
what is excel automation excel
automation
is a task automation involving excel
files
studio x enables the creation of
automation project
involving various types of data from an
excel file
using various specialized activities to
create an excel automation
we must use excel file resource when
creating a new project that
includes excel an excel file must be
specified
within it so that all of the subsequent
actions
can access the data contained within
that file
why use an excel automation ui path
allows you to automate excel in various
ways
such as excel application scope
activities
and workbook activities excel automation
simplifies your application by
performing tasks such as formatting
cells updating values and running macros
automatically
excel task in automated process can also
be integrated
with several other functions across the
enterprise using an rpa solution
the benefit of excel automation in
general
is that it can save people many are
spent manually completing tasks
advantages of excel automation
productivity excel automation provides
higher production rates
and increased productivity efficiency
some of the functions of excel can
easily create
automated tasks and custom logic with
functions like macros
macros are an excellent way to save time
on predictable
repetitive tasks hence excel automation
is efficient
better product quality excel automation
improves quality in several ways
including eliminating human error
increasing consistency and accuracy
the ability to create more complex
projects and the detection of mistakes
along the way
improved safety excel allows you to
protect your work
whether it's to prevent someone from
opening a workbook without a password
to grant read-only access to a workbook
or to simply
preserve a worksheet so you don't delete
any data
reduced labor excel automation will
perform all the repetitive tasks more
accurately and productively than humans
thus reduces labor reduced lead time
a lead time is the amount of time that
elapses between the start and finish of
a process
excel automation reduces the lead time
let's look how to install an excel
package
let's jump into the uipath studio to
install an excel package
go to the manage packages
you can see the packages that are
installed go to all packages
and search for uipath excel activities
by default an updated version will be
installed if the excel package is not
installed you can install it from here
so in my device
this activity is already installed so
this is the place
from where you can install any
activities or any packages
let's see some of the commonly used
excel activities
these are some of the commonly used
excel activities
redrain select range save workbook
autofill range copy paste
range insert and delete columns so
insert
inserting a column at the specified
location in a sheet
or a table or a range and to delete a
column
you can delete it from a specified range
or the table
there are filters filter table so what
filters does
is you can use the filter action to
create a filter in a range table
or a sheet based on the values in a
single column
we also have vlookup vlookup which
stands for vertical lookup
is an excel feature that when enabled
searches and retrieves data from a
specified column
we will explore all of these activities
in the demo section in detail
let's look at the demo in this demo we
have an
excel sheet that has a record of kovitt
cases
in five states of india in 2021
so we will create an excel automation to
represent the number of cases
in charge it's easy to understand
looking at the charts rather than
looking at the huge numbers
then we will upload the file on the
drive so
let's jump into the ui path studio and
get started
this is the excel file which i have
created it has
all the number of cases in this five
states
in the year 2021 the month of jan feb
march and april all this record i have
taken it from a website called
prs india dot org
so i have two sheets sheet one and sheet
two
so let's jump into the uipath studio
to start off with the demo we need to
have the
three packages installed one is the
ui path excel activities package
the other one is uipath g suite dot
activities
this activity this package is used for
drive top load on the drive then
the other package is balareva excel
activities
this package is used for bar graph
and pie chart
so after installing these three
packages we'll get started
so let's create a new sequence
name it as sequence 2
so first we'll drag and drop an excel
application scope
so excel application scope what it does
is
it opens an excel workbook and sets the
scope for excel activities
when this activity is completed the
specified workbook and excel application
are closed when the workbook application
variable
is specified in the output workbook
activities field
the spreadsheet is not closed
after this drag and drop a create table
activity
so by default we have sheet1 and
enter the range so the range is
in this excel sheet ranges from a1
to f5 so enter the range
for this we need to enter the
file path so we'll select the file
so we have selected the file we have
entered the
entire table name say
number of cases
so once this much is done next we'll
drag and drop a
bar chart
drop it outside the excel application
scope
and select the file path so
select the file
so select the file select this cell
range
that is the same range what we had
entered earlier
a1 to f5
so once that is done if the chart title
say basis
and you can select the chart type
bar stack 3d clustered 3d stand
whatever is required for now we will
select bar cluster
we have many other options to explore
data label type will keep it in
show value so that it shows the value
and select show value
if you want show percentage you can
select percentage
and select show legend and size
you can vary the size accordingly how
much ever you want
so i'll keep the size as
350
to 350. you can change the width
so the bar chart is done and you can
enter the sheet which sheet are you
using so it's sheet1
so we will drag and drop pie chart
select the file
similarly enter the options here
enter the cell range the same range
a1 is to f5
show percent will show value
show legend
select show value
and select the sheet which you want we
will select the sheet 2
so done so we have completed till here
next we need to upload this on the
google drive
so we'll select this option upload file
select the file
so we have selected define so select the
destination folder
for that go to your google drive account
so we will go there
so in my drive i have created a folder
called excel automation
so i'll copy this url
till here not the entire copy of this
and go to your ui patch studio
and paste it in the destination folder
you'll get double quotes
then create a variable and
create a variable as 5
oops there is an error we have forgotten
to use a g
suite application this can be only used
inside a g suite application
so drag and drop a g suite application
and inside g-suite application
will write this so that it's gone
so we'll run the file now we'll save it
and run
you can see the file is getting
run
so the execution is ended we will
navigate to the drive
so here you can see the file is
successfully uploaded
will open the file
it's working on the graph
here you go here you can see the bar
graph
for the sheet one with the values
number of values and each state wise and
for sheet two
we created a pie chart so here we go
here you can see the purchase
if you have any doubt any queries please
don't hesitate
to ask in the comment section we will
try to answer
all of your questions so with that we
have reached the end of this video
like and share it if you found it
interesting thank you for being here
keep learning and stay tuned to siblings
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here